wie kriegt man am besten frauen rum und
der mann von dem man es am besten lernen
kann heißt rolf eden und den gibt es
jetzt bei pixum der mann ist 82 und
schleppt immer noch 18 jährige ab wie er
das macht dieses geheimnis könnt ihr
jetzt erfahren
ja hallo größe lage welche lage ihre wie
immer fantastisch ja gar kein problem
weil sie sind ja schon älteren semesters
weiß ich nicht merklich nicht merken sie
nicht mehr hat es überhaupt nicht wirken
sowie 30 40 wird immer okay wie 30 40 ja
es hat sich bei mir nichts verändert die
damen sind zufrieden
sie kriegen ja gerne über sex ja gerne
ist es sehr wichtig aber sie machen und
daher das ist richtig nicht mehr so auf
das ist klar dass ganz normale
über 80 ist und so dass das man
sagen wir früher bist jeden tag gemacht
und jetzt einmal da war höchstens mal
wenn man es ganz besonderes ist im bett
liegt zweimal
wir haben eine freundin ja ich hab mir
da die süße freundin aber sie sind nicht
treu ich bin sehr teuer im herzen ein
bisschen welt im bett nicht träumen
treff geht das geht sehr gut sie ist ein
verstand sie weiß es und deswegen geht
das auch so gut mit uns sein mit meiner
freundin und mir aber es ist kein rezept
für eine dauerhafte beziehung war das
ist ihre wickelte
dauerhafte beziehung ja ich habe also 20
jahre verheiratet soll es ja geben bei
mir
sind ein erfolgreicher nachtclub sechs
klubs hatten sie und ihre fünf klubs und
fünf
und haben sich aber ein image aufgebaut
als der film berlins der berühmteste
playboy und ich sag mal der gerne über
themen wie sex und sonst was redet und
nicht mit hinterm berg hält warum meinen
dass sie peinlich es war ja auch mal der
freundlichste berliner sag nicht ja das
ist das war eine große ehre für mich bei
dreieinhalb millionen oder noch mehr
einwohner mit der aller fall ist dann
ist das sehr gut aber warum gehen sie
denn sowas gut weil das ist man was
besonderes und das war ganz wichtig zu
meiner zeit
nach lokal hatte hatte unser muss ich
sehr oft in den medien seien und welche
sachen inszenieren da wird das wirklich
interessantes
zu sagen aber ich habe keine freunde
hängt das damit zusammen oder ist das
auch nicht etwas wo ich sein also das
hat mir den peinlichsten berliner klick
so gerne freuen aber ich habe keine
freunde was man so freundin will sondern
noch mein kumpel war vor das will ich
alles nicht weil dann das brauche ich
nicht weil da muss man zur beerdigung
gehen und das wollen sie auch nicht auf
keinen fall ich war noch nie auf einer
beerdigung außer von meiner mutter
das würde ich auf keinen cent fällig ist
für nicht traurig sein ich würde nie in
irgendeiner weise belastet dass ich gehe
auch nicht so toll wenn leute hochzeiten
oder
oder wenn sie
wenn irgendwelche traurige sachen
krankenhaus habe ich auch noch nie einen
besuch so außer dass ich meiner mutter
war hat sich damals aber das war es auch
was weiß ich möchte nicht belastet
werden mit traurigkeit über das warum
soll ich das mein leben in anderer weise
belasten was dazu gehört
das gehörte überhaupt nicht dazu man
kann nur die schönen sachen im leben
erleben und das ist wichtig
es gibt so viele frauen auf dieser erde
und meinen job ist frauen zu beglücken
und nicht traurig zu sehen wie macht man
das
macht er das was die damen gerne haben
wollen im leben und da musste jeder ist
natürlich anders das gibt welche die
wollen eine kleine wohnung haben aber 62
zimmermann oder andere wollen die neue
nasa und das mache ich immer noch gerne
an den nasen war das gesicht schön ist
aber die nase ist also was
ich liebe persönlicher stups lesen
lassen sie ihren freundinnen stupsnase
machen ich habe natürlich das heißt ihre
ehemaligen freundin erkennt man an all
das nicht ich glaube auch viele die
haben von natur aus sehr schön oder
anderen ringen habe ich sie sich mal den
selben tag immer denselben ring von
cartier weil das ist ein sehr schöner
goldener ring mit 3 also ist ein
einziges drei regel sind das ist ein
ring aber so als 3d gemacht wunderschön
und das ist das wichtigste das ich dass
die sich untereinander kennen acht du
kannst auch
ich habe mein leben gehabt wie es mir
gewünscht habe sehr sehr sehr gut das
ganze leben nie großen erhards sehr
viele hübsche frauen also ich hatte
sicher mindestens über 1000 damen im
bett aber
das ist wenn man so alt ist wie ich das
ist ja nicht so viel wie viele sind das
in die adern also wenn man ich mache das
jetzt seit 65 jahren sehr gut sind schon
dann sind auch nicht so viel ja pro jahr
20 sind also ich hoffe es kommen nicht
auf solche zahlen freut es ist ja noch
sehr jung sie ist naja bekommen ist in
meinem alter sind haben sie noch mehr
dahinter junger mann ist also ist wenn
sie sagen sie haben mehr als 1000 frauen
gehabt haben sie hat nie angst gehabt
sich war erstens haben sie nie angst
gehabt sich was zu holen aids darüber
aber ich habe mein system die ersten
sechs monaten nur mit kondom okay und
wenn wir dann länger noch zusammen sind
hier geht es zum tochter und wenn er
sagt es ist alles gut dann kann ich
darauf verzichten vielleicht ok und dann
da bin ich sehr vorsichtig aus ich gehe
alle sechs uhr dass er auch zu machen
lassen so lassen sich untersuchen die
hatten ja
früher mal ein kleiner trick oder so
dass heute auch gar nichts meint eine
spritze war das nicht okay alles lange
her dass es am anfang noch nicht
aufgepasst haben ja noch gar nicht
wusste was das man sowas kriegen kann
also es gab sogar nichts zu der zeit
trifft das ist ja gar nicht
ich wollte mit mir auch nichts gelaufen
ist okay ich bin nicht unruhig aber
probieren kann ist ja mit sehr gut und
haben sie gesagt hat so ein bisschen
jetzt also
es gab schon mehrere den englischen nur
bei einer die mit mir im bett war schon
sagt in dem es mit so alt recht hat sie
lärm noch nicht gelaufen was soll's ja
aber sie hat nicht gerade das das war
vor ein paar monaten und jetzt hat es
nämlich wieder angerufen vorgestern aber
ich habe mir das anders überlegt kommt
lasst es uns wieder zweifel ich möchte
mit dir schlafen sehr gut dann werde
mein bestes geben und wie sie oder die
ist
18 oder 19 müssten
eine ganze person
ja wir kommen ja nicht an gott oder
ähnliches sondern nur irgendwann ist es
vorbei ist ich glaube nur an mich selbst
michael lang lebens war fantastisch und
dass dieses interview wenn er wird zum
thema playboy sehen wollt dann guckt
doch wie sex julia und ich uns auf der
playboy party so schlagen und was ingrid
und klaus zu dem thema zu sagen haben
und wie schnell sich klaus verlieben
kann was immer er unter liebe versteht
ihr wisst die beiden aus tv total die
immer die fernsehtipps zum wochenende
geben und ein anderes talk video ist
dann eher traurig mit den augen eines
auch super lustig mit den haudegen die
erzählen warum sie dann doch zuweilen
weinen bei ihren eigenen liedern ja und
ich soll ja zeit lassen zum auswählen
dieser beiden videos
das muss reichen bis das programm